did you notice like a change
um with gz's energy just like over time
like because like if you were around in
07 i feel like that was kind of jeezy
probably still
moving a certain way with a certain type
of people around him you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah i mean
a lot of people was just he ended up
getting that def jam situation which was
was that la that was later right uh he
was already he was always on death jam
no i mean i mean
atlantic or the atlantic yeah i was gone
by the end
yeah so yeah it's just like you'll hear
some people who around jeezy like super
early
and they'll be like yeah [ __ ] was like
real out like it was some real [ __ ]
going on and then
you know i mean it was active it was
some active [ __ ] going on we didn't got
into some [ __ ] before and it was real
activity
i can't knock that but just on some
loyalty and business [ __ ]
it wasn't it wasn't solid which explains
why nobody [ __ ] with him no more and
it's just like and then look and like i
think
like again like i'm a fan of jeezy i've
been around him he's a nice guy
i don't have any personal issues with
him but just like from a fan's
perspective you'll look at like cte and
you'd be like dang no one ever came out
of cte
and you could say yg he had he had guys
but you could say yg but yg was already
on def jam
and they kind of just threw the cte
through it and then yeah
i think that i kind of got in his ear
about that [ __ ] but i left in the midst
of that
like the whole yg going on i told i told
jesus i said man it's the guy he finna
be the next [ __ ] up
well we was in colony i'm like and i
told just incredible we unplug drama
computer and plug just incredible up
because we're telling drama playoff yg
[ __ ] like who was that i'm like what
[ __ ]
unplugged this [ __ ] bro plug in just
incredible [ __ ] up man play that yg [ __ ]
i'm texting my boy to text him tell him
what songs to play
i'm telling him in jeezy ear it's my
birthday too so i'm drunk you're feeling
well
i need that [ __ ] no watch now i'm
telling watch how this club turn around
he play one joint boom play another
joint boom
the crowd the club just turned up from
there i'm like well it's the [ __ ] if
paru
young homie he got like a situation at
def jam i don't think they know what to
do with it you need to pull these
strings bring them over here he's like
yeah well this [ __ ]
ain't got fun to get up my chain we
finna come over here and
uh no no hold up hold up hold up but i'm
i'm telling this [ __ ] like he's the guy
bro this is because we're in the condo
in
in atlanta every morning i'm waking up
playing yg nipsey
you know what i'm saying the [ __ ] that i
that we listen to out here and they lie
man you playing that [ __ ] i'm like what
you mean this is the [ __ ] that we
playing in l.a this is what's going on
yeah and um and i leave 30 days after
that we fall out
30 60 days after that and then i
remember
i remember um some mixtapes coming out
you know what i mean and then we i hear
them on songs and taking pictures i'm
like okay he didn't rant
it's happening it's cool though i never
was like mad about it or not like that
you know what i'm saying
and it just turned into what it turned
into